on chat commencer bien sûr par
l'ouverture d'euro disneyland le royaume
de mickey a accueilli ce matin ses
premiers visiteurs avec une heure
d'avancé au bingo renie les stars de la
voici aux adorateurs de la petite souris
une vraie famille française de villepin
que la première à s'être présenté au
guichet ce matin grâce à mickey elle a
gagné la postérité et surtout un
abonnement à vie au royaume magique
comme elle des milliers d'anonymes venus
de toute l'europe ont fait le siège du
parc dès 6h ce matin
impatients de découvrir ce nouveau monde
à l'américaine
bienvenue au monde magic d'euro
disneyland pas plus organisés que
week-end une trentaine de caisses des
sourires on ouvre les portes une heure
avant et le tour est joué
225 prend d'entrée c'est cher mais le
rêve ça n'a pas de prix
cadeau pour la filière
peut-être on espère se rappeler un peu
de john a
on a vu aux états unis et voilà mais
c'est magnifique
donc on a voulu être là aujourd'hui pour
le premier jour on retrouve une enfant
une joie on est vraiment remis et tant
pis pour les esprits chagrins cette
amérique de rêves colorés déguisé peuplé
de fées de personnages de dessins animés
les européens en redemande
dépaysement assuré par 29 attraction
très bien rodé ils étaient venus pour
les gosses ils sont sous le charme
subjugué par le souci du détail de la
machine disney ça me paraissait de
l'enfantin peu foire de pacotille je
trouve que c'est très bien
tu as beau monde agréable moment je n'ai
pas la maille adultes
enchanté comme les organisateurs qui
affiche ce soir un sourire satisfait
mais refuse de communiquer le nombre
d'entrées par superstition ce soir
l'oncle picsou va faire ses comptes bien
réel en espérant que le bouche à oreille
marche à fond et que la petite souris
gagne son pari de 11 millions de
visiteurs par an